hello everyone it's time to pick the
winner of my 10,000 subscriber giveaway
the lucky winner will be awarded the
official digital chest walk by feed is
DGC 2010 but before I pick the winner I
would just like to show you a very nice
game by the magician Mikkel Tao it was
played in 1964 inter-zonal tournament in
Amsterdam and Mick Hotel is playing
against gurgling of strong Bulgarian
Grandmaster Mikkel tile is white and
Ringo is black so let's see this short
miniature a 17-2 miniature to be exact
we have a four by tau g-sibs
d4 Bishop to g7 we have an ID to see 3d
six night to f3 c6 Bishop to g5 now
Queen to b6 we have Queen to d2 queen
capture 7b to sort of a poisoned pawn
variation we have worked to be one
attacking the Queen Queen to a3 Bishop
to c4 we have Queen to a5 tower castles
we have e six now rook F 31 we have a
six Bishop f4 and now II five and
topless D captures on e5 we have D
captures on e5 and now very nice tall
move Queen to d6 living this bishop on
high for hanging and also this knight on
c3 hanging and the tingle captures the
knight on c3 and play screen captures on
C 3 so we have rook to d1 threatening
Queen to d8 checkmate and the string of
tries to defend this by playing Knight
to d7 and in this position make Hotel
actually has a forced checkmate in 8
moves and he finds it immediately
he plays Bishop captures on f7 would
check we have King captors on f7
Knight to g5 check we have King te 8 and
star plays Quinta ecigs check and in
this position at the Bulgarian
Grandmaster resigned because what's
following is King to be 8 we have
tonight to f7 check King to c7 and
simply Queen to d7 checkmate so yeah
like I said a very nice miniature by
McHale table and onto the giveaway so
let me just turn off one of the layers I
think this is it okay so this is a
website called common speaker calm
/youtube dot html' and this is the
website we'll use to pick our winner so
here we'll just enter the YouTube URL so
let's just do it here I pasted it here I
press GO and now he will see all the
comments here okay amount of unique
comments is 186 so I guess 186 of you
will be participating with this event
and since I can't really filter out
those of you who wrote hashtag tile I
will just press the start here and the
start speaking of the winner but
unfortunately if I pick a winner who
doesn't have hashtag tile in his comment
then I will simply have to pick another
winner
those were the rules of the giveaway so
let's get on to it and let's press this
start button and see who the lucky
winner is so here we go okay
he's searching searching searching it's
certainly very random and okay we have
the winner a mr. X Republic of gamers
who unfortunately simply wrote hashtag
tile but the rules clearly clearly were
you have to write something about some
excel towel and then after your comment
press spacebar and write hashtag towel
so we will have to pick another winner
unfortunately so let's just repeat this
I'm pretty sure I will have to refresh
the page here call it just refresh it
okay let's do it one more time okay we
paste it here and let's go picking a
random winner someone who actually wrote
something and added a hashtag style to
this and okay we have a winner
and it's victor is board and the Victor
said top games inspire me to play better
to play more complex and rise to a new
level I thank you for the videos as they
have definitely helped me on my way to
becoming a master here in the States
hashtag towel and well seeing everything
seems to be legit here and the victor is
board is definitely the winner I
congratulate you mr. victories board and
you are the winner of the official fides
digital
clog the dgt 2010 you will have to
contact me here by any social media but
you will be required to contact me by by
this user account and send me a message
or private message or something through
youtube so i can verify that this is in
fact you and yeah that's it
congratulations man
I do hope you enjoy this clock is it
pretty I mean it's the best clock there
is to play chess on definitely my
favorite and once again I congratulate
you and that is it for this event I hope
to do more of these I don't think I'll
be able to do more of these before maybe
reaching 20,000 subscribers but
hopefully I will try and make this
fairly often event so this is it I do
hope you enjoy the game and the thank
you all for participating in this event
and thank you all for watching the
videos and the commenting liking in the
world
all in all contributing to my channel in
any way possible
so that's it you can check two of my
previous videos here as usual and until
the next event audition